hello did that appeal to you
did you click subscribe because the tone
resonated in a fun and friendly way hey
guys welcome to Friday re if you don't
know for diary's look back at my week
and vlog form and I didn't film very
much this week at all whatsoever this
has been a kind of chill week just been
getting work done so I didn't film a ton
of stuff but here's what I did film this
week
[Music]
reunited and it feels so good that we're
so emo watch
what are we even looking for a future
even she couldn't handle that one hello
happy Monday to all of you today
has been a day bless you guys I started
off today by having to go to the DMV to
get some new paperwork for my license
and I had made an appointment a couple
weeks ago and the thing about the DMV is
you can walk in well the thing about the
DMV is it's an awful awful place
[Music]
I've been waiting for two weeks for this
appointment finally went got into the
front of the line because I had an
appointment if you walk in it was like a
50-person line insane
got through got my paperwork sorted all
the way up to my counter like the third
counter I was supposed to be at and it
was to the final moments of the
appointment and the man asked me if I
had $27 to pay with and they took cash
check or debit card all of which I did
not have I only had a credit card and
because it's really hard to make a DMV
appointment the quickest appointment I
could get was at a DMV that was
forty-five minutes away from where I
live so I didn't have time to run home
get cash and run back before they closed
for the day because that's the thing
about the DMV they are a fickle
temptress so I have to make another
appointment for another day and the
quickest appointment is like two weeks
from now or something like that so to
console' myself and my anxiety and
frustration I went to Ikea and I bought
a console table for all of this that's a
lot of a lot I'm gonna put this together
because I don't have enough frustration
today
NIT tour it's just me and you let's do
this
I'll see your turquoise because I'm
quirky so it appears that the directions
are telling me to one create a
genderless alter-ego and then have an
identity crisis with said alter-ego so
we can do that right after and don't
though get fixed just give me this for a
second I only took a few years off of my
life and I only took one shot of whiskey
out of pure unadulterated frustration so
yeah good job thing please don't break
copy juice everybody its podcast day
look who's here Kenan we just found the
podcast and we found the challenge in
which my arms like shaking because I
just assumed really gross things so I'm
gonna go find a way to make myself feel
whole again not gonna happen
I'm at dinner with a couple of [ __ ]
Wow that's a minimal amount of clips
grace you should do better next week and
I will but in the meantime I didn't want
this video to be so short so I have a
surprise gift for you my friend Brian
Graham oh who did all the
behind-the-scenes stuff for the grace
Helbig show has edited together a
channel reel for me and I wanted to
debut it in this video for you guys
Ready Steady Go hello there what you're
about to see is video will be very
compelling and so god damn moving I said
could be great
[Music]
after a long day of work or just like
staring at any wall I like to make
myself a light refreshing meal something
that's just super heavy and kind of
depressing and full of sodium if you
follow your fear and you say yes to a
situation or an opportunity sometimes
you will find yourself in a really great
place
someone called doctor I got a case of
the field if they do know that my rug is
dirty you clicked on a video of a grown
woman doing the yoga challenge with
their dog so well let me just say right
now baby now we got bad I'm menstruating
I know it's not in this room but it
reeks of recent farts goose goes good to
mine English Wow I'm on the floors of
trying to exercise and beep ow subscribe
if you like this subscribe if you're
like that good morning welcome to Friday
re-fry Diaries Hey look back at my week
what do you call a democratic cheese a
shark left when your spray tan goes
wrong we're on set shooting photos
lecture 1 diner girl we're outside you
outside you when I come home my mom goes
through everything ridiculous she has in
her closet to give me and she just
happens to pull out a mr. potato it's
all about collaboration
[Music]
James Corden this [ __ ] phone get rich
it sprays in a way she's even gone so
far as to use a comma there playing
though what's up my butt challenge I
just make a phone call this is the phone
peppy farting near you even on your
worst day try to make it a good day for
someone else and I thought that was such
a philosophy taking over scrotum is
showing
no I don't know
please don't go well that was awesome
thank you Brian Graham oh poor that
Channel real you'll see that get
uploaded by itself as a trailer to this
channel so there you go that's what
happened to me this week and I hope you
guys had great weeks next week is VidCon
which is gonna be intense so I should
have more footage from there or this
next week don't forget to like this
video if you liked this video or if you
don't like this video just lie to
yourself and click like anyway that
would be really cool of you the greatest
gift you could give me is lying to
yourself leave a comment down below what
did you do this week and don't forget to
subscribe so then you don't have to be
someone that is not subscribed to this
channel because science proves that
those not subscribe to its grace live
sadder lives I don't know
[Music]